what's going on you guys ready to see
some animals love was actually this is a
pretty sad looking place will we do that
again we do that again Carla was a
little scared all right it's an exciting
time because it's time for our annual
trip to be shirring hayden Nina Evan and
my niece and nephew Stephanie and
Jeffrey with your cheeks and later to be
joined by my friend Louie fresh and it's
raining and his son Skyler Skyler with
Daddy skooshy cheap and Nina has some
work to do was daddy solution so she's
joining us two days later which means
that I get to take the kids without Nina
and they're all going to behave right
yeah and you guys get to join us every
stroke over work we made it in we met
Louie hey
the kids are playing on the iPads hey
kids and the flight is delayed by an
hour so even later getting in with four
kids so we'll we'll see we'll have some
fun you guys are going to you're going
to sleep really well tonight right and
be really well-behaved right I did you
go that didn't sound very convincing I'm
keeping my fingers crossed all right we
are at the late again so we're gonna get
in 1140 weeks and then get the car and
then get there oh man so far the kids is
in a while Hayden's eating some timbits
kyle is working on this computer that's
bigger than him Stephanie what are you
working on fella purpose be mad I don't
know what that is Jeffrey's playing so
far there okay how's Louie doing I'm
good I'm good Louise good any good hey
guys r on airplane it's gonna be so much
fun 3-4 Lando and we're gonna go to
Florida and you guys are gonna sleep a
lot on the plane right
130 in the morning just got the kids to
bed stopped off at Wendy's because we
were starving to get some food while the
kids slept I didn't want to wake them up
usually I'm like up in the morning let's
go guys we have a schedule I'm worried
that they're gonna get sick if they
don't sleep well so we set a rule that
whoever's the first to get up wakes
everybody up we don't have an alarm for
tomorrow hopefully that works the Airbnb
place is pretty cool quick tour this is
the master this is where Nina and I will
be once Nina gets here the waters are
kind of funky so we're gonna open you uh
get some bottles hopefully tomorrow we
got a living room we have a Louie we
have a kitchen and then over there
there's two bedrooms in another bathroom
that's it time the white down relax wake
up tomorrow start day one
one it's seven o'clock in the morning
the kids slept terribly techne woke up
and have to have water at five in the
morning Jeffrey without the tutelary and
then Hayden woke up early this morning I
couldn't get much sleep we were
splitting them up tonight so they
actually get some sleep good idea and so
that Evan can get some sleep too she's a
great idea because i haven't sleeping is
a great idea I agree so we're gonna get
ready and then head out to animal
kingdom you guys ready to see some
animals it's Disney World exciting so
far okay we're gonna open up soon
alright is that fun all right we came
for breakfast time us breakfast time
lunch time this feast is 58 US dollars
so you don't you don't really get
bargains coming to disney but are you
guys ready for your pizza yeah yeah me
pits all around and of course some
broccoli and carrots for the kids so my
allergies are acting up the grass here
Nina's bringing some medication from
home my areas which would be good for
them sneezing and sniffling and Louise
getting into accidents here with the
kids
you guys are let them cool with your
glasses we do that again we do it again
Oh Carla was a little scared Stephanie
looks really scared like where's Jeffrey
thank you what are we watching do you
like it it's hot so it's ice cream time
Hayden already has it all over his face
look at that what a mess Jeffrey doesn't
have anything to say yeah stuff is
enjoying Skylar went with healthy fruit
bar love was the bus is still hate in
space what I'm a semester
good octave miss murkly was that fun
guys
very creepy what do you think's Kylie
all right end of the first day we're
heading out we ended with the bugs life
which was fine red guy people are tired
you know and what and hot tired and hot
and sweaty look it we didn't sleep much
last night so we're going to go and get
home do some food shopping so we're not
just eating carbs and eating out make
Nina something because it's her birthday
so it just shows up there's something
special for her and get ready for a busy
busy day at Epcot tomorrow look at the
tree of life behind us that's nice so
did you guys have a good first day yeah
all right Hayden you look tired you okay
mr. you're okay okay I go like the name
Louise and Annie it wouldn't be possible
today without glue at your hand oh yeah
we got back kids slept for an hour in
the car they said that it felt like they
were only in the car for two minutes two
seconds I was dreaming about going to a
concert I was dreaming that I was like
at school I was having a nightmare that
I was gonna get in the car accident Oh
Rosalie I was driving I was driving me
can be a little bit dramatic at times he
freaked out on my allergy issue here but
uh you kind of be am a drama queen over
there Louis all right it's dinnertime
chef Louie even the meats gonna be what
are we having this is a perfect just a
park roses pork loin it's nothing could
not make that myself this guy was
enjoying that carrot supplement and meet
then someone and salad her name used to
cooking for three knots yeah this is a
pretty sad looking place how does it
taste guys yummy I guess this Louie cook
that means I'm on Dish duty